>>> CNN has learned that former
president trump will huddle with
his legal team at mar-a-lago
this weekend as a potential
indictment looms over his
alleged role in hush-money
payments made to adult film star
stormy Daniels.
A source tells CNN trump is
weighing whether to appear
before a New York grand jury
that's investigating the
payments that were made days
before the 2016 presidential
election.
Manhattan prosecutors have
invited trump to appear.
CNN senior legal analyst and
former federal and state
prosecutor Elly Hoenig joins me,
elii, I feel like when I read
the title of your book, it is a
perfect segue to our
conversations.
What do you think trump will do?
He's not going to talk to the
grand jury.
He's not going to do that.
>> Absolutely not.
No.
N-o, no way.
There would be no reason for him
to do that.
This is an unusual feature of
New York state law.
This isn't just the prosecutors
being nice and giving him a
chance to do this.
They have to give any potential
defendant a chance to come in
and testify in the grand jury.
That's actually not the law in
many states.
That's certainly not the law
federally.
There's no upside here.
Donald Trump is not going to
talk a grand jury out of doing
whatever it might do.
All he can do is give
information that can be used to
incriminate him.
In this case or in many of the
other civil lawsuits and pending
criminal investigations against
him.
So easy call for Donald Trump
here.
Thank you for the invitation,
but I respectfully decline.
>> We've been talking about the
stormy Daniels case for years
now.
And you and I have talked about
it for years now, I feel like.
Does that timeline matter
legally?
>> So legally it does not
matter.
Some people have asked about the
statute of limitations which
usually is five years, meaning
you have to charge a case within
five years of when it ended.
Here these payments happened 6.5
years ago.
The thing is, New York
prosecutors are going to be okay
on that count because there's a
law in New York state that says
if somebody has been
continuously residing outside of
New York state, you put that
clock on hold.
So they're well within the
statute of limitations.
Jim, the amount of time that has
passed here is going to make
this prosecution more difficult
for the prosecutors because it's
harder to stand in front of a
jury and argue about something
that happened that long ago and
make them believe that it's
serious and urgent.
To an extent the amount of time
that's passed is going to make
this a tougher job for
prosecutors.
>> And trump's lawyers are
saying that this case is
unprecedented.
I suppose that is the
understatement of the year.
Are they right?
>> They're right in hay couple
respects.
First of all, of course if
there's an indictment we know
this would be the first-ever
indictment of a former
president.
That would be historic.
That would be unprecedented.
But they're also right as a
matter of law because the theory
here that prosecutors appear to
be using is, first of all,
they're going to charge it looks
like falsefications of business
records which is a misdemeanor,
meaning basically these were
hush-money payments, but they
falsely booked them as attorney
fees.
In order to bump it up to a
low-level felony prosecutors
have to prove it was connected
to some other crime.
Here they will argue it was a
campaign finance crime relating
to the presidential election.
What we don't know here is this
is a state-level prosecution,
the campaign finance violation
was federal, relating to the
race for president.
And there's flow -- there's no
law on that.
That will have to be decided by
a judge.
That's unprecedented, as well.
>> In your book you reveal the
southern district of New York
decided not to proceed two years
ago.
Does that give insight into
what the outcome may be here?
>> Legally it does not matter.
It doesn't mean that the
Manhattan D.A. Cannot prosecute
this case.
They can come to a different
conclusion than the feds, my
former office across the street
did.
Also we're dealing with
different sets of law.
The Manhattan D.A. May have come
up with new evidence that the
feds didn't have two years ago.
That said, I think it's
important, I think the Manhattan
D.A. Would be well advised to
consider the fed's logic.
Look, the feds, when they looked
at the cases, the southern
district of New York, they
believed that the evidence was
sufficient to charge but not
overwhelming, and the southern
district of New York was wary
about the political factors.
They were wary about the fact
that this felt, a, old, and, B,
fairly low on the list of
trump's misconduct.
So this is a difficult call for
any prosecutor.
There's no necessarily right or
wrong answer.
But I think the Manhattan D.A.
Would be well advised to at
least look at what the thought
process was there.
>> And aside from trump and
stormy Daniels, the other key
player is Michael Cohen, trump's
former fixer who's been very
critical, sharply critical of
the former president.
Does that complicate things?
We all know Michael Cohen, we've
heard from Michael Cohen a lot.
He was on this program last
week.
He does not pull his punches
when it comes to his old boss.
>> He does not.
Michael Cohen looks like he's
going to be a pivotal witness in
this case.
On the one hand.
Michael Cohen clearly had
insider access, he was in the
middle of this transaction.
He pled guilty to it, and many
of the things that Michael Cohen
has said since he did his prison
time about Donald Trump have
been proven out to be true.
On the other hand, the reality
is like it or not, Michael Cohen
is going to be vulnerable to a
searing cross-examination.
He has been convicted of
perjury.
He has been convicted of tax
fraud and financial fraud.
He denies that he did it, but he
pled guilty to those crimes.
Michael cone has a white-hot
hard for Donald Trump.
On cross-examination they're
going to argue this guy despises
druch, he'd do anything to --
Donald Trump, he'd do anything
to get him.
Michael Cohen is going to be a
key witness here.
I understand why one may want to
rest the case on him, I get
where prosecutors are going.
But make no mistake, defense
liars are going to have a lot of
hay to make on
cross-examination.
>> And of course just one of
several cases that may be on the
horizon for the former